nouveau portrait de notre série avoir 20
ans dans les années 2020 bamba gueye
guillaume des mâles nous présente le
parcours de maëlle la politique
l'intérêt si les mêmes militants mais
pour défendre avant tout les idées des
jeunes
ces lieux c'est dur
c'est dur d'avoir un temps en 2009 c'est
tout
bonjour je m'appelle miles bonnaire j'ai
19 ans je suis en deuxième année de
licence de droit et je suis aussi
militant au mjs 21
c'est à dire le mouvement des jeunes
socialistes de côte-d'or c'est un
mouvement autonome du parti socialiste
et on sait surtout des collectes des
actions des tractages et on soutient des
candidatures évidemment politique
et puis d'aider des petites actions
concrètes du quotidien je prends un
exemple le le tarif réduit de
l'abonnement divia mensuel pour les 18
25 ans c'est le mjs qui l'a proposée
soumis au conseil municipal qu'il l'a
votée
j'ai toujours voulu apporter un petit
plus la société en participant à un
collectif qui oeuvrent avec des idées
que je pense juste et équitable
je pense que ça vient de mon côté
paternel mon grand père était maire
d'une commune est depuis ce depuis ce
moment là je pense que j'ai une
attirance pour pour et la politique
[Musique]
mars c'est la journée des droits des
femmes et donc en fait on s'est dit on
va lancer la campagne sur les réseaux
sociaux pour qu'on soit visible si on
fait une vision souvent pour discuter
des sujets d'actualité des luttes qu'on
a en commun des des échéances
électorales à venir voilà on trouve une
date
c'est magnifique ça tellement
d'initiatives qui viennent des jeunes
qui sont pas mises en avant et ben
hammam el il fait partie de ces
centaines et milliers de jeunes qui
s'engagent et qu'on met pas assez en
avant
le tournage rien
dans sa cave
est ce que vous avez reçue mais aussi
genre à la rentrée on revient en disant
en présentiel une semaine jour pour jour
le personnage le beaucoup de personnages
il est toujours pas dire street dans ses
idées mais très très ouvert d'esprit
quand même c'est un peu le papa du
groupe
on va dire quand on est parti en
vacances c'était vraiment c'est lui qui
gérait un peu tout ça tape des grosses
barres avec lui et les i
il est cependant mais vraiment il est
génial quoi ils travaillent tous les
noms et leurs vacances comme tout le
monde un record depuis que le connais on
dit lui il va être président après s'il
n'est pas aux pavés aux moines on pense
qu'il est capable
après on verra six ascensions c'est le
président c'est tout le temps même des
fois en soirée il a évolué jeudi le
discours le discours il est là il fait
il fait son discours c'est non en vrai
jeu franchement je le vois lyon métro
d'audrey parce que ça se voit qu'il est
fait pour ça il a une aisance à parler
dont 20 ans et finir que 40 ans je me
vois avec veut un travail une famille
[Musique]
dans leurs yeux
pire comme ils disent et comme ils
chantent